[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour qui comment quand et pourquoi
contre qui comment contre quoien estassé
de vos
violenceces d'où vlez-vous où allez-vous
qui êtes-vous qui priez-vous je vous
prie de faire
silence pour qui comment quand et
pourquoiil faut absolument qu' voi
contre quelqu'un ou quelque
chose je suis pour le soleil couchant en
des collines désertes je suis pour les
forêts
[Musique]
profondes car un enfant qui pleure qu'il
soit de n'importe où est un enfant qui
[Musique]
pleure car un enfant qui meurt au bout
de vos fusil est un enfant qui
Meur que c'est abominable d'avoir à
choisir entre deux
innocences que c'est abominable d'avoir
pour ennemi les rir de
l'enfance pour qui comment quand et
combien contre qui comment et combien en
perdre le goû de
vivre le goû de l'eau le goû du pain
celui du Perlin Pinin dans le soir des
bâtinones mais pour rien mais pour
presque rien pour être avec vous et
c'est bien et pour une rose en
trouvelle et pour une respiration et
pour un souffle d'abandon et pour un
jardin qui
ferit
rien à voir mais panément ne rien se
dire et perdument mais se donner avec
I et riche de dépossession navoir que sa
véritéer toutes les
richesses ne pas parler de poésie ne pas
parler de poésie mais laiss vivre les
fleurs
sauvage et faire jouer la transparence
au fond du NO cour murerie où l'eaua
jamais sa
chante pour qui comment quand et
pourquoi contre qui comment contre quoi
pour retrouver le goût de
vivre le goût de l'eau le goût du pain
celui du Perlin pain pain dans le soir
des
bâtigoles contre personne est contre
rien contre personne est contre rien
mais pour une rose
[Musique]
ouverte
et pour une respiration et pour un
souffle d'abandon et pour ce jardin
[Musique]
qui et vivre vivre
passionnément se battre seulementc les
feux de la
tend rich Deir sa
vérité
richesse ne plus parler de poésie plus
parler de
poésie
et faire jouer la transparence au fond
d'une cour murguerie où l'Auve aurait
enfin sa chante et vivre vivre
passnément et ne se battre seulementc
les feux de la
fende les riches de les possessions noir
que s vérité toutes les
richesse
rien que la
tendesse pour tout richesse donnez
donnez
avecre
ch avec T de je vivre
vivre avec vire ser de la tendresse pour
toute resse donnez
donnez avec vivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]